combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait deux
papas plus jeune neuf autres
de quoi monter bien sur vos droits
[Musique]
thacker pâte à tarte tatin zut
venez tous je vais vous montrer ma
dernière invention qu'est ce que c'est a
moulins à café un moulin à café sera pas
non un aspirateur un aspirateur
maintenant il est ou stupides et c'est
pas ses cheveux mais non c'est une
caméra projecteurs avec ça je vais vous
filmez et vous verrez ensuite comme à la
télévision
[Musique]
oh
bravo papa pas à moi et c'est super
gage de la pellicule et humer monsieur
bougon au collège d'ailleurs je suis
prêt
[Musique]
cette fois des plus jolies
à
tu es tu te met en veilleuse
merci patata si tu veux je te donnerai
une photo dédicacée bas qu'est ce que
j'en ferais tacle où il faudra qu'il met
le bougon belle idée mais ça lui dire
par surprise
comment faire est ce que c'est que ce
bouquin une fois passe encore mais une
fois c'est trop je faisais de la musique
le thé moque pas de moi pas tu as juste
en face à 10 voix pour vous embêter
il avoue le chapeau il a ce tout petit
nom d'eric là je vais te donner la
correction que tu mérites mon jardin et
pourquoi parceque vous attend seulement
filmé par la caméra de patates loup film
et sac à papier
vous auriez pu prévenir j'aurais mis mes
médailles je suis bien comme ça
je peux sourire si vous boudez et quand
pourrais-je me voir sur un écran dès ce
soir
oh
une seconde s'il vous plaît un petit
problème technique
comment ce jeu me le sommeil
astuce en france
l'invention n'est pas tout à fait au
point
heureusement beaucoup dormi bravo bravo
nous avons beaucoup de talent moi
surtout encore merci pour ce film
superbe eva joly bonne nuit fais pas ta
plus
[Musique]
oh